have you ever been tempted to compromise
your values I have not been tempted to
compromise my values because for me I've
been leading the effort of my
productions
I'm they've been my productions and so I
haven't had to run against any type of
executives or executive producers that
have asked me to compromise any of my
values and to be honest and I'm really
kind of thankful that you asked that
question because it makes me reflect on
why I got into this industry and to
begin with and what I didn't think was
possible I didn't think it was possible
to get to where I am without
compromising my values and I remember
when I was like 20 22 years old I came
to LA with a script that script that I
had made between you and me that I
thought Spike Lee was gonna pick up I
came to LA and I was here for six weeks
and I recognized in order for me to be
successful I'm gonna have to compromise
my values so I immediately went right
back home because I was like this is not
for me which fast forward these few
years later I'm here and I haven't had
to do any of that so I'm really grateful
without naming any names or exact
situations what did you feel you would
have to do and what how would that be
compromising well the thing that I
learned about LA when I first got here
is the is how the community kind of
works here I'm a very like spiritual
person I'm not really religious I'm not
a I'm very much impact and in order to
not be affected by those energies I
can't be around a lot of people and I
saw that when I first got to LA you have
to find a crew of people to kind of run
and to kind of hang out with and so I
could see myself being in circles where
people were talking negative about other
people in order to make themselves feel
better and that's not me you know the
you know kind of drugs things that kind
of was going on and I'm like that's not
that's not me either
like I don't judge anybody for what they
do but it's not necessarily who I am but
I'm also not like a religious zealot you
know I'm like a little bit in between
there's a guy
to eat good food and go to the movies I
want to do and so I just kind of could
see a lot of those influences happening
and a lot of those floors influences
taking a group and I was like okay I'm
not ready for LA but now that I'm back
while I still see some of those same
things again I'm able to address it a
little bit different than what I was in
the past I have the strength now to say
no plus you have a body of work yeah so
at that time when you came you had just
a few scripts just a few scripts just a
few scripts and a whole lot of naivete I
really think I really did I had no idea
how the film industry in LA works and in
this past year that I've been here well
I don't I can't say I'm like an expert
I've really been able to see and witness
how the industry works and it makes a
lot more sense now that I see how I can
navigate through it and plus you know
you can put a production together yeah
did it yeah so whether you were totally
happy with the project the outcome is
one thing but you know you can get
people together you can get resources so
I'm sure that exudes a different energy
so maybe then they know ok well this guy
I can't totally I can't pull the wool
over his eyes when I got here so one of
the first things that happened when I
got here was people different production
companies would hit me up for a
different meetings but I remember having
this one meeting and this guy he was
talking really quick really really quick
very good Gary is at a very attractive
personality very attractive personality
and he was talking about like I was send
me your script I want to look at your
project
I sent him over just like a deck of what
I wanted to he was like this is a
perfect project and then he starts
talking about that he can do these
certain sales on the film prior to just
to get started all you needed was like
$15,000 and I I know when I was younger
not that I had 15,000 but if I would
have had it I knew I would have given it
to him but now I'm able to know the
business and I know that I don't have to
give you $15,000 for me to go getting
money for my feature film but again you
start to see these characters and you
start to see how people conduct
themselves and know like oh that's not
what I want to be associated with and so
I was evilly I was easily able to say no
this time where when I was younger I
wouldn't have been able to do that so he
wanted that upfront money to take on
your film to take on my film project and
then to get funding for it but I just
never heard of that structure that
finance structure that he was saying so
it made sense that this was more of a
scam and it was an honest reality or
someone who just wanted to work with me
almost like modeling agencies that'll
take you on yeah if you use their
photographer and these different things
yeah this upfront it was almost like
that like it was project hadn't finished
or wasn't even me no project wasn't made
it was just a screenplay at the time I
still have this being played but he read
the screenplay
said it was incredible which of course
was part of the the manipulation and one
end money wanted about $15,000 to get
just to get started and then he said you
know he's he's able to work a deal
within like 6 to 8 weeks and I'm like
none of what you're saying makes any
sense and so you were 21 and you went
back home yeah with that knowledge did
he try to call no this happened this
year oh that got happened this year if
that had happened to me when I was 21 oh
I would have given them whatever I had
because I would have thought this is
this is how you this is how you make a
film this is the business and it's not
the business and I know the business
because I've studied the business act
you know more appropriately so yeah this
just happened like maybe like six months
ago oh okay sorry my bad okay and so how
did that make you feel knowing like you
you could have been taken advantage of
but you knew better like how does that
you made me feel so accomplished the one
thing that I have learned how to do is
say no and that's sometimes I have to
say no to myself like hey I want to
write this certain project know that
project isn't for you
it's not authentic oh great and so now
I'm able to flex that muscle so it was
nice for me to look him in his eye and
tell him no thank you
it was it was empowering and again I
wouldn't have gotten there had I not
done my feature had I not done my
digital content had I not gone through
these scrapes and these bruises to know
what feels right and what feels wrong
and have the power to be able to to say
no
you